We're gonna go play outside more now Rosa!
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This is good to be my new black Adam and Shazam
2 video the rock and the shazam people were
hyping up the DC fandome comic con panels
they're going to be doing later this summer.
So we'll break it all down I'll also explain
what's going on with the justice society in
the movie as well as the Henry Cavill Superman
crossover that they been talking about.
If you're new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's going to be panels for pretty much every
upcoming DC movie with them showing off footage
for the stuff that they do have in a bunch
of concept art and teasers for the stuff they
haven't started filming yet.
So will do is all talk about what's going
on with the black Adam movie first then I'll
talk about shazam to starting with number
five the rock confirmed that they were doing
a special black Adam movie panel at this DC
fandom of at the summer originally, they were
supposed to start filming the black Adam movie
in July until the virus hidden delayed everything
the still semi-later this year.
There filming shazam to a little while after
that originally they were going to film them
both at the same time, because the kids from
the shazam lay are growing up so fast the
trying to get those sequels out as quickly
as possible before they get super old.
Also part of their reason originally for filming
the movie simultaneously was the way they're
intending on crossing the black Adam character
over with the shazam lay in the future sequels,
so all explained that to because it's a little
more complicated than your standard Justice
league Batman Superman crossover some of those
crossover plans changed a little bit because
of what happened with the virus, but for the
most part their larger plan is still intact
the black Adam movie is just intended to be
a straight up prequel telling of his basic
origin story, but the black Adam movie is
connected to Justice league in the DC EU through
the shazam movie.
That's also why they're talking about doing
Henry Cavill inside the black Adam movie in
some way and really cool site detail number
four originally, the rock said that they started
developing the movie to be the original shazam
movie a long time ago.
He does producers were actually the ones who
said they went to Warner Bros. and convince
them to take black Adam out of the first shazam
movie and do them as two separate movies so
they could do his origin story is black Adam
separately from what they were doing during
the shazam movie right after the first shazam
movie came out he was edgy talking about it.
That's why his production company is listed
in the credits of the first shazam movie.
There were a couple.
Deleted scene from the first shazam movie
involving black Adam like the one I attached
to the beginning of this that clip for Darla
and the shazam we are sitting down the thrones
and the rock of attorney starting to wonder
who that seventh throne is supposed to be
for Darla says it doesn't matter who it is
what they've done they're going to accept
them as part of the family that was kind of
the ark of the first shazam movie, realizing
that Billy's biological family didn't really
want him.
So the family that he made for himself was
his true her family.
It's kind of the same situation with black
Adam post all the fast and furious Vin Diesel
family means you want to.
So that scene with Darla and the family on
the thrones, there is actually meant to be
a teaser for black Adam's entire story arc
through all the shazam and black Adam sequels
he starts out hating them also wanting to
get rid of them and claim their power for
himself, but through their adventures like
the DC rebirth comics they're adapting for
the shazam sequels he comes to realize that
their necessary inserts to accept them, but
he's never super best friends with the shazam
like it's more like a temporary alliance that
will wind up lasting forever black Adam spends
most of his time when he's not fighting people
in Khandaq in the middle east Billy in the
shazam we are the ones that spend most of
their time around the rock of maternity.
So, number three what's going on in the black
Adam movie what's up with the DC EU just society.
If you didn't see it last year the rock revealed
that they would be introducing the Justice
Society of the DC movies in the black Adam
movie there been a lot of different reports
about how they're going to handle the Justice
Society directory doing a version of them
on the stargirl TV show right now to but
is not to be those actors from the TV show
showing up in the black Adam movie is going to
recast different actors the black Adam movie
is going to take place during a couple different
time periods black Adam became black Adam
around 5000 years ago in Khandaq the Backstory
they're going with.
According to the rock is his slave Backstory
this with the combining couple different comics
he became a slave was eventually freed started
to the family than the Council of wizards
of the rock maternity selected him as their
new champion seeing his potential a warlord
comes to conquer the area around Khandaq.
His family was killed.
He wasn't able to save them.
The Council of wizards didn't do anything
to stop them.
So he blames them and after killing the warlord
succumbs to the seven deadly sins frees them
from their prison like Dr. Silvana did in
present day they killed most of the Council.
That's his movie Backstory's is little bit
different from the comics, the kind of combining
couple different things.
Eventually, the wizard winds of trapping the
seven deadly sins again and then is able to
eventually trap black Adam in a magical prison
it because the just society is appearing during
the movie during couple different time periods
the rumor right now is the part of the original
just a society in the past helps the wizard
trap black Adam and then in present day after
black Adam escapes his magical present a new
version the Justice Society has to re-form
to try and stop him from wreaking havoc, but
mostly he just trying to find a way to bring
his family back, so it's the things that he
does on route to that that put him at odds
with the Justice Society.
They haven't formally announced who the actual
villain of the movie is going to be like who
is worse than black Adam their only a couple
people like that in the comics in the rebirth
comics they're adapting for shazam to is actually
Mr. mind in the monster society who are worse
than black Adam, but because they're doing
them during the shazam sequels.
They might choose a different villain for
the black Adam movie like Felix Faust or someone
else before they work their way up to full-blown
monster society, because that sort of like
a big villain team up, but number two.
What's going on with the DC EU just a society
in which characters are going to show up during
the black Adam movie.
They haven't really been featured in any of
the DC movies yet.
I just did a video for the Justice league
Snyder cut trailer that Zach Snyder dropped
yesterday so will post a link to that at the
end of this but during that I talk a lot about
this big dark side war flashback scene the
Green Lantern that you see during this flashback
scene was named the Yalan Gur so after his
Green Lantern ring left to seek another lantern
to replace him.
His body was taken back to OA, the Green
Lantern Corps and became part of their star
heart experiment that would eventually power.
Alan Scott's Green Lantern battery between
the different versions.
The just a society that they talked about
doing the black Adam movie.
The characters that we've heard about so far
are Dr. fate Hawkman just because he's such
a big black Adam character a version of star
girl in present day Adam smasher who you saw
during the flash season two cyclone who they
haven't done in any of the movies or the TV
shows yet.
And maybe some Easter eggs for some of the
bigger characters like the specter but that's
just a rumor right now.
So just open up a tab in Chrome and I'll do
another video if they confirm it, the number
one what's going on with shazam two what are
they doing on these comic con panels the shazam
post credit scene is the supposed to be a
teaser for the black Adam movie.
For those that were confused about that, it
just a straight up teaser for the plot of
shazam to that they're pulling from the shazam
rebirth comics.
Mr. mind explains the seven realms of magic
to Dr. Savon in his prison cell there.
He wants to control them and free the monster
society from the monster lands the seven realms
of magic are different dimensions that are
separated inside the rock maternity black
Adam also had a hand in helping separate each
of them to protect the earth lands.
The earth lands are basically what you would
call our dimension that contains the main
DC universe that also serve as the opportunity
for black Adam to eventually team up with
the shazam Lee in future shazam sequels basin
with Zachary Levi said their current plan
is is for black Adam to appear in shazam three.
Whatever that movie would be called we don't
have a subtitle for it yet.
As for Henry cavil crossover in these movies.
The reason why they talked about putting Henry
cavil in the black Adam movies because the
rock is good friends with Henry cavil in real
life that is a management company and he's
signing a new contract to appear in about
three different upcoming DC movies so black
Adam is just one of the movies he could appear
in shazam to is another one for the most part
these panels which are all happening on August
22.
I'm expecting the price just give us a bigger
preview of what's going on with the black
Adam movie with the story the rock confirm
that he's going to be at that panel.
So he's going to explain everything then during
the shazam to panel the also probably do the
same thing to because they have asserted filming
the movie yet.
So most of the footage you see is really just
concept teasers and mash ups of the characters.
Zachary Levi also did say that eventually
shazam would be joining a version of the Justice
league when they did get around to doing another
Justice league movie even though is going to
be a long time before that happens to expect
them to continue to reference the Justice
league characters a lot during shazam to everyone
post all your shazam to in your black Adam
predictions in the comments below.
If we get anymore updates about what's going
on are more teasers of course I'll do videos
about it way way for everything.
Click here for that Justice league Snyder
cut trailer and click here for my brand-new
Henry cavil Superman video
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!